[Musique]
elle représente un département français
que peu de gens sont capables de situer
sur la carte et cela fait d'ailleurs
partie du combat de mon invité fire de
maotte un département comme les autres
ni plus ni
[Musique]
moins bonjour estou bonjour alors vous
avez étélu député 2022 sans le soutien
d'aucun parti politique c'est assez rare
on peut le souligner vous siégez
aujourd'hui au sein du du groupe Lyot et
alors à l'Assemblée vous portez presque
tout le temps ce châle que vous avez
aujourd'hui sur vous avec des fleurs
d'yangilang vous l'avez d'ailleurs sur
votre photo officielle de de député il a
une signification politique particulière
ce Châ c'est une couleur qui est très
banale à maillot qui incarne le combat
des chatouilleuses les femmes qui se
sont battues dans les années 70 pour que
Maillotte reste française chatouilleuse
et donc oui parce que les les
combattantes chatouillaient les
émissaires Comoriens ou français qui
essay de nous convaincre de
l'indépendance et donc pour humilier ses
bonhommes on les Chatou on les
chatouiller alors votre père était Maora
Maora bah c'est le nom des des habitants
de de maotte vous êtes né en région
parisienne vous y avez grandi au début
puis vous avez passé votre adolescence à
Mayotte jusqu'au bac ça veut dire quoi
pour vous être maoraaise est c'est une
double culture aussi
c'est c'est une des facettes de
l'identité de la France même si la
France le méconnaît mais nous on est on
est des Français depuis 1841 et oui ça
fait même si Mayotte effectivement a des
traditions et des cultures très
spécifique par rapport à celle de
l'Hexagone mais enfin comme beaucoup de
traditions ultramarines elles sont
particulières alors moi je fais un petit
rappel historique parce que c'est vrai
que tout le monde ne connaît pas
forcément l'histoire de de Mayotte il
faut savoir que les habitants de Mayot
ont voté plusieurs fois pour rester
français quand le reste de l'archipel
des Comores a fait le choix de de
l'indépendance et depuis 2011 Mayotte
est officiellement un département
français cette identité française vous
elle est profondément ancrée en vous
vous n'en avez jamais douté non mais le
fait que vous posiez la question traduit
bien le sujet entre les hexagonaux et
mayottes autant nous on n' pas le
moindre doute sur le fait qu'on soit
français autant la plupart de nos
compatriotes ne sauraient pas
effectivement nous situer sur une carte
où ne savent pas que nous sommes
français avant Nice et la Savoie et donc
c'est vrai qu'on est une poussière dans
l'océan Indien mais l'attachement à la
mer patrie est très important parce que
c'est une protection et c'est un choix
effectivement c'est pas quelque chose de
subi contrairement à l'histoire d'autres
territoires ultramarins après le bac
vous vous êtes éloigné de Mayot pour
faire des des études en métropole pour y
exercer un un métier qui vous a donné à
l'époque une certaine notoriété parce
que vous avez été journaliste à la
télévision présentatrice de JT notamment
sur LCI
vous avez été aussi correspondante
d'aljazira à Londres vous avez été
reporter à France 2 pour l'émission un
œil sur la planète qu'est-ce qui vous a
attiré vers ce métier de journaliste euh
je voulais voyager et j'étais curieuse
je suis toujours très curieuse et j'aime
apprendre et donc j'ai été journaliste
pendant 20 ans j'ai étudié en fait au
Canada aussi j'ai toujours voulu voyager
alors vous avez ensuite arrêtter le
journalisme pour devenir consultante en
affaires internationales vous avez
organisé des forums en Afrique vous avez
aussi intégrer des réseaux d'influence
internationaux notamment les fameux
young leaders je crois que vous faites
partie de la même promotion qu'eddouard
Philippe à l'époque pourquoi avoir
renoncé au journalisme ah j'ai j'ai j'ai
eu des graves problèmes de santé qui
m'ont j'ai eu j'ai un cancer du sein
j'ai dû repenser la vie que je menais
être dans un métier moins stressant et
puis la tournure aussi qui a pris le
métier avec les réseaux sociaux euh j'ai
été c'est vrai l'objet de becou beaucoup
d'attaques sur les enquêtes que j'avais
pu mener et à chaque fois la virulence
des attaques qui étaient très
personnelles sur les réseaux sociaux et
l'attitude de certains collègues en fait
confrères qui avaient embrayé dans ce ce
dialogue ce discours de haine m'avait
fait me sentir de moins en moins à ma
place dans le milieu alors 2018 a été
une année charnière pour vous le décès
de votre père vous a ramené à Mayotte au
même moment l'île vivait une crise
sociale assez profonde et à la fin du
mois d'AV la chaîne Mayotte première
vous a proposé de remplacer au piedlevé
un invité dans la principale émission de
débat politique on va revoir un extrait
de cette
émission moi je pense que Mayotte n'a
rien à faire avec les Comores si ce
n'est d'entrenir des relations de bon
voisinage qui s'arrête là je pense qu'il
faut se souvenir des propos de Bamana on
peut être voisin frère même père même
mère sous é toit différents les maorés
sont maorés français les Comor sont
indépendantes et comoriennes qu'ell le
reste et qu'ell s'éclat avec leur
indépendance laétionionale ne peut pas
se faire au dépend merci beaucoup on a
l'impression que vous êtes entré en
journaliste sur ce plateau télé vous en
êtes ressorti en femme politique en fait
à l'époque j'étais arrivé sur le plateau
on m'avait parlé de questions
institutionnelles sans me donner la
thématique de la discussion et en fait
effectivement le débat a porté en partie
sur les relations avec les Comores sur
lesquel j'ai une analyse
très précis et donc des positions et que
j'ai alimenté et ce qui a beaucoup
surpris en fait à l'époque parce que je
dis les choses très franchement h alors
vous avez tout de suite été repéré on
peut le dire par un collectif de
citoyens qui vous a demandé de devenir
leur porte-parole peu après cette cette
émission c'est comme ça que que tout a
commencé pour vous un an plus tard vous
vous êtes retrouvé placé en garde à vue
avec votre frère à l'occasion de la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron à Mayotte vous
avez été arrêté pour avoir voulu vous
rapprocher de l'endroit roit où il
allait tenir un un discours ça a eu quel
effet sur vous cette cette arrestation
euh c'est quelque chose de très violent
de j'ai des séquales physiques mon frère
aussi ça a été un traumatisme parce que
mon engagement n'a toujours été et né
que républicain h et de se voir imposer
l'arbitraire et la violence contre un
combat qui demande plus de
justice plus de reconna naissance de la
part de nos institutions moi qui suis
fille et sœur de militaire c'est quelque
chose qui a été très choquant c'est
quelque chose qui aumtis c'est votre
détermination votre volonté de vous
engager politiquement ça ça pour moi ça
a été intraumatisant et ça m'a
radicalisé dans l'idée que pour que moi
une petite mouche fasse face à à à
l'éléphant institutionnel c'est que je
devais avoir raison et donc ça m'a
convaincu qu'il fallait continuer le
combat et qu'on touchait quelque chose
de vrai et de sensible alors en 2022 le
collectif des citoyens de Mayotte vous a
demandé de vous présenter au législativ
vous expliquez que vous n'aviez pas
vraiment envie d'y aller mais qu'otte on
ne s'appartient pas qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par là qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire on s'appartient pas c'est
euh allir non chez les insulaires en
fait le collectif est capital parce que
sur une île vous dépendez des autres
pour votre survie donc la logique
fraudienne de l'individu quand vous êtes
sur une île ça n'existe pas vous
appartenez à un groupe et vous votre
avis personnel vient après Mayotte est
dans une situation de crise extrêmement
grave et en fait nous on avait travaillé
pendant des années pour que les élus
reprennent nos revendications et nos
propositions travailler considérablement
et le fait que nos élus n'ai pas pris le
relais en fait avec la population on
s'est dit bon bah très bien puisqu'ils
veulent pas le faire on va le faire
nous-même et donc on va t'envoyer tu es
président du collectif et tu vas y aller
et effectivement c'est pas quelque chose
où de la même manière que j'avais pas eu
le souhait quand quand j'étais allé sur
ce plateau de télévision d'entrer dans
dans dans l'engagement et la politique
de la même manière en prenant la tête du
collectif je m'imaginez pas arriver à
l'Assemblée nationale alors sur la scène
politique Maures vous avez un style qui
détonne quand même c'est un style à la
fois très direct vous aimez bien les
punchlines vous avez beaucoup de
répartis et ça vous vaut d'être surnommé
député pimon oiseau le piment oiseau
c'est un petit piment qui est
particulièrement fort il faut le savoir
vous dites que votre façon de faire de
la politique ne correspond pas forcément
à la culture mahoraise euh alors il faut
savoir que le piment dans la cuisine
mahoraaise c'est l'ingrédient
indispensable donc ce qui paraît pour un
pala occidental quelque chose d'un petit
peu agressif chez nous c'est un
compliment un bon plat il y a du piment
dedans d'abord et moi en tout cas je le
prends comme ça et c'est dit avec
beaucoup d'affection à Mayotte on
m'appelle putumoa donc c'est vrai le
piment oiseau mais effectivement on a eu
et on a traditionnellement ça revient
vient encore à l'insularité on a une
approche qui est toujours de créer du
consensus et de ne pas faire perdre la
face à nos interlocuteur ce qui est
normal parce que vous vivez avec vos
adversaires sur une île c'est un espace
clos or moi effectivement je pense qu'à
un moment il faut cesser des hypocrisies
et que on se dise des choses et
j'accepte tout à fait le désaccord j'ai
aucun problème avec ça mais je souhaite
qu'on assume chacun ses positions vous
hésitez pas aller au clash avec vos
adversaires c'est pas d'aller au clash
c'est que juste qu'on soit clair qu'on
dise les choses je je n'aime pas
l'ambigué parce que l'ambiguïé à Mayotte
elle a nourri des décisions qu'on a pris
malgré nous et et et nos élus avaient
tendance à ne pas assumer leur choix et
en fait la clarté impose ensuite la
responsabilité et donc c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement je suis très directe
dans mais c'est aussi l'héritage d'avoir
été pendant 20 ans journaliste où on le
le langage journalistique est tout sauf
ambigu ce qui est l'inverse du langage
du politique alors au-delà de votre
style il y a aussi vos prises de
position qui ont pu choquer parfois en
2019 vous avez appelé la France à
envoyer je cite des fusillers command
pour dynamiter les usines qui fabriquent
les quissa quissa ce sont ces barques
par lesquels arrivent les Comoriens sur
l'île de de
Mayotte envoyer des commandos pour
dynamiter des usines dans un dans un
autre pays c'est vous y allez pas de
main morte c'est je rappelle que le
président Hollande avait envoyé des
commandos en Syrie parce qu'il estimait
les intérêts français menacé par des
opérations qui se tenaient en Syrie de
la même manière pour nous à maot
qui constatons l'arrivée plus la moitié
de la population est étrangère sur notre
île toujours par le même véhicule qui
sont des quissa quissa je n'appelle pas
à attaquer ni envahir un autre pays je
dis allons détruire le lieu où on
fabrique ces engins de mort de trafic
humain que sont les quissaquissa mais ça
rend déclarer la guerre don on sait dont
on sait la France n'a pas déclaré la
guerre en Syrie et pourtant elle a mené
des opérations parce que nos intérêts
stratégiques étaient menacé donc moi
j'appelle sur un constat de dire que
c'est une menace de déstabilisation ce
ce flux migratoire à Mayotte menace
notre souveraineté c'est pas moi qui le
dis c'est tous les premier ministres
successifs depuis 10 ans j'ai j'appelle
mon pays à prendre les mesures à hauteur
du sujet de façon ferme vos adversaires
vous reprochent d'être sur la ligne du
rassemblement national à la fois sur les
questions d'immigration et de sécurité
et vous avez eu une phrase qui semble
confirmer dans un article du Monde vous
expliquer sur les questions migratoires
et sécuritaires on est d'extrême droite
sur les questions sociales on est
d'extrême gauche ça veut dire que vous
assumez une forme de proximité avec avec
le RN sur ces deux thématiques alors
vous savez vous avez un petit outil
assez sympathique les algorithmes de
Data Assemblée nationale et vous avez
l'historique de mes vote et vous verrez
que je suis proche de nupes je rappelle
simplement que euh le la question de la
souveraineté est malheureusement
monopolisé par l'extrême droite alors
que les questions migratoires en tout
cas pour Mayotte sont centrales et c'est
le constat de tous moi je déplore que
les autres partis ne s'en emparent pas
je je suis assez claire là-dessus je
pense que que au contraire on doit avoir
un débat sur les questions d'asile et
d'immigration qui soit partagé et pas
laisser le monopole de ce sujet à
l'extrême droite on va terminer par
notre quiz à présent je vous explique le
principe je vais commencer une phrase ça
va être à vous de la compléter on y va
j'écoute j'aurais réussi mon mandat si
j'arrive à améliorer la vie de mes
concitoyens à Mayot avoir de l'eau
courante ce serait une grosse réussite
pour mon mandat avoir autre chose qu'une
maternité dans notre hôpital ce sera une
grosse réussite avoir des routes
supplémentaires départementales ce
serait une grosse réussite pour certains
députés Mayotte c'est un problème un
problème oui parce que c'est un mystère
c'est un mystère et un problème
c'est-à-dire que ça les empêche et je
les empêche activement de de voir les
choses de manière simpliste enfin être
député c'est renoncer à beaucoup de
choses on met sa vie privée entre
parenthèses c'est can B c'est
chronophage c'est c'est très exigeant
c'est magnifique parce qu'on est au
service de la population et vraiment moi
je pense que c'est un privilège un
honneur que j'aurais jamais imaginé mais
oui c'est c'est un sacrifice merci
beaucoup sou d'êt venu dans la politique
et moi mer
[Musique]
merci